الخبز اليومي له معنى خاص في
مخبز الجزار هذا ،
لا توجد آلات هنا تحتاج ياروسلاف إلى
العجين يدويًا
خارج أندريه يقطع الحطب
للفرن في وقت أدت فيه موجات
الضربات الروسية إلى شل شبكة الكهرباء في أوكرانيا ،
حيث أثبتت الطرق القديمة أنها
مفيدة.
لتمضية أيامه ملتصقًا بشاشته في وظيفته في I.T أعادته الحرب
إلى ما هو أكثر أهمية
مما حدث الآن في أوكرانيا ،
إنها حقيقة في كل العالم
وأصبح الناس أكثر وعيًا
وأكثر امتنانًا
لكل ما لديهم الآن
في  حياتهم في
وقت سابق من هذا العام عانت bucha خارج كييف
من احتلال روسي وحشي
وكان مسرحًا لما
يقول المحققون إنها جرائم حرب
دوقة تحب الزبون المنتظم
يقدر الخبز وروح
أولئك الذين يجعلون الرجال اللطفاء
شركة صغيرة لطيفة أتذكرها  بعد
تحرير الجزار مباشرة ، بدأوا في
خبز الخبز وحتى تقديم هذا
الخبز مجانًا للمحتاجين
، كما قاموا بتوفير الخبز والترا
معجنات إضافية لمن هم بعيدون عن المنزل وفي
طريق الأذى ،
بعض هذه الأرغفة مخصصة
للجنود شيئًا إضافيًا قليلاً
سيجعل ليلة رأس السنة الجديدة
تذكيرًا خاصًا بموسم الأعياد معلقة
على
عملهم ، ولا تزال ذكريات الكوابيس الأخيرة لا
تزال موجودة  جديد وشبح المزيد من
الهجمات الروسية تلوح في الأفق
الاحتفالات الكبيرة سيتم إسكاتها
في أجزاء أخرى من العالم يمكن للناس
الاعتماد على الراحة وانتظار
الألعاب النارية اللطيفة يخبرني ياروسلاف أننا
قلقون بشأن الألعاب النارية ،
فإن رغبة إيرينا للعام الجديد بسيطة
نأمل ذلك  ستكون أفضل تقول إننا
نأمل أن تنتهي الحرب
لا يستطيع المرء أن يعيش على الخبز وحده ،
كما أن هناك حاجة أيضًا بن ويتمان سي إن إن أوكرانيا